Hi everyone. 10X. You feel it yet?
Hi, my name is Aurel Zion and I'm a
mobile software engineer for the last 14
years. And I'm here to talk to you today
about 10X, reimagining the mobile dev
workflow.
So you know, back in the old times when
cursor was that thing you make with your
mouse and AI agents were that dystopian
character from sci-fi books or movies,
whatever fits your style. You know, just
a few months back. Back then when we
thought that we will still be using our
IDEs just maybe slightly better.
And now we know that we already switched
to like chat style
engineering when we discuss with Claude
Card, Codex, Cursor, whatever.
And we just tell them what to do and we
don't use our IDEs unless it's for
debugging or something that the agent
couldn't figure out.
And that, in theory, should have made us
10 times more productive, right? That's
what everybody says, right? Wait, are we
10 times more productive? Do you feel
it?
I don't know cuz I can't feel that we
are 10 times more productive, not as a
single engineer, not as a whole group,
and not as the whole company.
So, why is that? Why don't we don't see
the promise of 10 times more productive
come to an actual life?
So you know, they tell the story about
how when factories switched from steam
engines to electric engines, at first
they didn't see that big of a gain. So,
yeah, the
electric engines were better, they were
more efficient, but they didn't see that
10X, 20X, 30X
more productiveness that they have been
promised.
And the reason for that was that they
only changed the steam engine with the
electric engine.
But the real gain came some years
afterwards when they understand that
it's not only about changing the engine,
it's about changing the whole workflow.
Cuz you see, they used to have like one
giant big steam engine in the factory
and all of the machines were rearranged
based on their power consumption and
their proximity to that steam engine.
So, it wasn't organized by the workflow
that it should have been, like from the
start to the end of the workflow. No, it
was designed by proximity to that
central engine. When they realized that
and they also realized that they could
take the electric engine, make it
smaller, and put it inside each machine,
and then they rearranged the factory to
make it work as the workflow should
because now it it was made possible,
then the real gain came. Now they were
10 times, 20 times, 30 times more
productive than they were before. Not
because of only changing the engine, but
of changing the whole workflow.
And that is what I want to talk to you
about today. Let's think how we I make
things that weren't possible possible
now and we can change our workflow and
then becoming 10 times, 20 times more
productive.
To do that, let's look at the current
workflow. The PMs have an idea, they
iterate with the designers, they iterate
with the user, they iterate with the
dev, they iterate then back with the
designer, then they iterate with the QA,
and they iterate back with the dev, and
maybe after all those iterations, maybe
you have something in production.
So, what was that word that was
repeating so many times? Yeah,
iteration. And this is the problem.
Cuz iteration creates friction.
Each iteration creates context switch,
create
time waste, creates communication that
needed to be done, sync synchronization
that needed to be done.
And AI didn't eliminate all of that. AI
sped up code, but didn't eliminate the
friction. Didn't eliminate the
iteration.
Why is that?
So,
let us reimagine what we could do.
Bear with me for a moment. What if What
if What if instead of using one tool for
designing, another one for testing,
another one for coding, and then another
one for releasing?
What if we could use one tool, one code
base? What if instead of designing on
Figma, sending our design doc to the
developer in order for them to figure
out how to
um make those uh designs alive? What if
designers could actually design on code
and then send the developer a PR?
What if QA could iterate with the agent
itself, just getting a link with the
simulator, and they can tell the agent
exactly what to test, what to be
cautious of,
and if they find something, exactly what
to fix?
What if we could make the dev workflow
works
on the code itself? What if God was one
of us? No, sorry, I got carried away
there.
And you're probably asking,
how can we do all of it?
So, one way would be to tell everyone to
just download their Xcode and and their
Android Studio and teach designers and
PMs and QA how to build and how to uh
test on simulators, emulators, and bloat
their laptops with a 200 GB on storage,
and uh whatever they do to the to our
memory.
That's one way.
But, let me guess that most of them
would reject that idea. And for good
purposes.
So, we can make another way. Maybe we
just put it in our CI, right? So, we let
the agent iterate with the CI, so they
don't have to download Android Studio
and Xcode and everything.
But, you actually know that CI builds
take between 20 to 40 minutes, and we
can't actually let our agent wait for 40
minutes just to understand that the iOS
code that it pushed actually failed to
build.
So, what else? What can we use?
Introducing cloud sandboxes.
So, cloud sandboxes are actually concept
that has been around already for many
years, just not for mobile development
yet.
Using cloud sandboxes, you can tell the
agent, "Here's an Here's a CLI. Talk to
the CLI. Create a VM, a small VM that
runs only for this iteration.
The VM boots up in 30 seconds or less,
make the build, show them a simulator on
their in-app browser in the cloud code,
codex, cursor, whatever."
And then they can iterate over it, tell
it to change that button, uh to go back
and test something,
and change the code, and they push an
open up PR, and then the designer can
work on code, send a PR to the developer
after they're done. Developers make any
iterations, make one, two, three, four
different VMs uh to run in parallel.
They send the PR for review.
QA can take it from there and tell the
agent exactly what to test and tell it
what to fix.
And from there, it goes straight to the
stores for review.
So, let's see it. Let's see how it
should work.
So, imagine you see this screen.
Imagine you're inside codex, for
example. You have the chat interface to
your left, you have the actual app to
your right.
The designer is iterating with the
agent, tell it exactly what they want
them to do, what they want to change,
and see the changes
immediately on their screen.
Build time is faster, it's done on the
cloud, and preview time is faster.
Then they iterate some more, not with
the developer, but with the agent on
their laptop without the need to install
Xcode or Android Studio.
And once they're done, they can tell the
agent to take that code, open up PR, and
send it to the developer.
This workflow is what makes us 10 times
more productive. Not only because of
using AI, but because of using AI to
change the workflow, reimagine it, and
remove all that friction that we took
from for granted
in the old times.
That is how we become 10 times more
productive.
Thank you.